قُتل ثلاثة جنود أمريكيين يوم الأحد الماضي
في الأردن على يد ميليشيات عراقية
تدعمها إيران، وردت الولايات المتحدة يوم الجمعة
بضربات على مواقع عسكرية
في العراق وسوريا تستخدمها إيران
ووكلائها خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع، كما ضربت الولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة
مجموعة أخرى مدعومة
من إيران.  اليمن الذي يضايق
السفن الدولية في البحر الأحمر هو
الشرق الأوسط يتصاعد إلى
حرب أوسع فالي ناصر كان مؤخرًا في
المنطقة وهو أستاذ في جامعة جونز
هوبكنز مينا العرابي هو
رئيس تحرير صحيفة الدولة الوطنية
في أبو ظبي أه  فال دعني
أبدأ معك بنوع
السؤال الملح في الوقت الحالي وهو
أنك رأيت هذه الهجمات التي
قامت بها الولايات المتحدة ردًا على
أه لهجمات المليشيات من
الحوثيين وأه والآخرين يفعلون  هل
تعتقد أن هذه الميليشيات
ستتصاعد أم تعتقد أنها اعتبرت
ذلك بمثابة
رد فعل محدود إلى حد ما محسوب من قبل الولايات المتحدة.
أعتقد أن مقتل
الأمريكيين الثلاثة جلب نوعًا من
لحظة الحقيقة لتان حزب الله وهوس
كل شيء  معًا لمعرفة ما إذا كانوا
يريدون الذهاب إلى أبعد مما
فعلوا أم لا وأعتقد أنهم لا يريدون
التصعيد أه إلى
مواجهة كاملة كاملة مع الولايات المتحدة
لقد توقعوا أن ترد الولايات المتحدة
أعتقد أنهم سعداء  أن
الولايات المتحدة لم تضرب إيران، وأنها
ضربت أهدافًا محددة
ارتبطت بها بأعمال معينة
لهذه الميليشيات، وأعتقد أن
الإيرانيين قد نشروا على الأقل في
الأخبار صحفهم ووسائل الإعلام الخاصة بهم، حيث
لم يقتل أي إيراني ولم يقتل أي إيرانيين.  لو كانت
المباني هناك فارغة مما
يعني أنهم لا يعلنون عن وقوع
إصابات تتطلب التصعيد، لذلك
أتوقع أن
يتعين على الحويين والميليشيات العراقية إظهار
نوع من رد الفعل ولكن لن يكون
على المستوى الذي قد يتصاعد  هذا
الصراع وذلك يعتمد على
ما ستفعله الولايات المتحدة بعد ذلك و و أه و
فال فقط أعطونا فكرة مرة أخرى
أحد الأسئلة الأسئلة الملحة
هو كيف تتصرف هذه
الميليشيات أه بشكل مستقل أه كما تعلم هل من المحتمل
أن إيران خططت و  وأه وسحبت
الزناد على هذه الهجمات
التي أسفرت عن مقتل
جنود أمريكيين لا أعتقد أن إيران
أو هذه المجموعات أرادت قتل
جنود أمريكيين لأنهم كانوا يعلمون أن
ذلك سيكون جسراً بعيداً جداً والولايات
المتحدة  سيكون عليهم الرد بقوة شديدة
أعتقد أن
الإستراتيجية العامة هنا هي مهاجمة الولايات المتحدة،
مهاجمة إسرائيل، تعزيز
المكاسب الإستراتيجية التي حققوها في
7 أكتوبر والاستمرار في
التأكد من فوز الغوريلا أه أه
وخسارة الجيش الإسرائيلي التقليدي  كما
ذكرت في مقدمتك لكني
لا أعتقد أن كل قرار يتم اتخاذه
بسبب إرهاب
أه ولا يتطلب الأمر سوى شيء كبير مثل
مقتل الجنود الأمريكيين الثلاثة
الذي قد يؤدي إلى
هذا النوع من القيادة
والسيطرة التي أعنيها هناك  لقد تم
تنفيذ 160 هجومًا علينا أهدافًا أكثر من
ذلك وربما ولكن في الوقت الذي
نتحدث فيه ولا أعتقد أن كل واحدة من
هذه الهجمات تتم إدارتها من تيران، أعتقد أن
إيران أعطت دعمًا واسع النطاق بأن
هذا هو الوقت المناسب  للضغط علينا
وعلى إسرائيل لكن لا أعتقد أنهم قادرون على
إدارتها بالقدر الذي
نفترضه
أه مينا هذا أه يخلق شيئا من
المأزق أه الكثير من دول الخليج
ليس لديهم حب لإيران إنهم
لا أحب هذه الميليشيات التي
كثيرا ما أه تثير المشاكل للسعوديين
أه الحويين في اليمن كانوا
عدوا لدودا ومع ذلك كنت في المنطقة أه أه
منذ 10 أيام هم حقا لا يريدون
حربا أوسع صحيح الذي  هو الذي
أه هو المسيطر الآن
الرغبة في ضرب أه إيران بمعنى ما أو
الرغبة في عدم ترك هذا
ينتشر إلى شيء
أوسع أود أن أقول إن
الأولوية الأساسية في الوقت الحالي هي عدم
السماح له بالانتشار أكثر أه ال  الخليج
يتطلب الاستقرار، يريد دائمًا رؤية
التهدئة، هناك
مخاوف كبيرة بشأن هذه الميليشيات، دعونا لا
ننسى أن السفن هاجمت كلاً من
الإمارات العربية المتحدة والمملكة العربية السعودية قبل أن
يهاجموا السفن في البحر الأحمر،
هناك شعور بضرورة
وضع حد  على هذه الميليشيات الأردن
والهجوم الذي قُتل فيه الجنود الأمريكيون الثلاثة
كان على الأردن، وكانت هذه هي
المرة الأولى التي تستهدف فيها هذه
الميليشيات الأردن بشكل مباشر،
وبالتالي هناك قلق من أن الأمر سيخرج
عن نطاق السيطرة ولكن
القلق الرئيسي  في الخليج في الوقت الحالي يتم
التوصل إلى وقف لإطلاق النار في غزة، وهو ما
سيزيل بعض الأعذار التي
تستخدمها هذه الجماعات للتصعيد أكثر،
ثم ثانياً رؤية
استراتيجية أمريكية جادة حول كيفية التعامل مع
هذه الميليشيات مرة أخرى، والتي كانت هذه الميليشيات
تحصل عليها مرة أخرى.  أقوى وأقوى على مدى
الخمسة عشر عامًا الماضية على الأقل، وكان جزء من
ذلك بسبب غض الولايات المتحدة
الطرف عن رؤية أنها تستطيع التعايش معهم
طالما لم يتم
استهداف قواتهم، ومع ذلك فإننا نراها تتصاعد
عامًا بعد عام.